eh bien mes premières questions en gros
quels sont les plus grands défis dans la
gestion d'un musée bienvenue dans la jungle
bientôt vous serez confronté à un
animal sauvage car vous savez tous que l'
instinct de chasse est déclenché par la faiblesse si vous
montrez la peur que l'animal vous chasse  vers le bas
mais si vous restez parfaitement immobile, l'
animal ne vous remarquera peut-être pas et vous pourrez vous
cacher dans le troupeau en sachant
que quelqu'un d'autre sera la proie
matin monsieur playa Majora's
bien c'est l'hôtesse pour fils musclé
[Musique]
puis à moitié  vous ne pouvez pas encore
essayer une
dinde au bacon Aoife comique
[Musique]
vous ne pouvez pas encore essayer d'avoir des relations sexuelles avec beaucoup d'autres
femmes, une sorte de question privée son nom
vous